[Music]
always a pleasure to see you sir huh
thank you man good to see you uh was
this a role that you went after how did
this thing happen for you because you
and Seth have some great chemistry it
was a you know my agents they they told
me about the film you know they send the
email with the sides and all that and
when I saw Seth and Charlize in it like
we have to get this and you know I
remember auditioning for it
seth is there while you're doing the
read so you know we're trying to see if
we have chemistry together and he asked
me if I wanted to take the the sides
into the room and I was like nah dude
I'm trying to impress you so you know I
had everything memorized ready to go
ready to knock it out
and just to show him that I was ready to
work that even though it's a comedy I'm
I will be here to be the utmost
professional I'm here to knock it out
the park and I think that's what got me
the rope I haven't said it yet but the
movies I laughed my ass off watching
this he is so so good Jonathan told me
though his first cut was like four and a
half hours that's probably mad funny
right I was like wow and he was telling
me some of the stuff that was was cut
did you remember anything that was cut
oh you remember every one of your jokes
that was cut every time you made the
room laughs you remember right so you
know there's definitely some stuff that
I could see how he wouldn't have fit you
know where the direction the film was
going and I love the the finished
product of long shot
Jonathan is so good at balancing you
know real life drama and real you know
sensitive moments with comedy and
keeping it hilarious and keeping it
light you know he's really good at that
and we have such a well balanced film
that I think it's perfect uh are you a
little bit listen you just got into
acting in the not so distant past like
four years ago
yeah are you a little bit because you
kind of won the lottery a little bit
with the projects you've landed Godzilla
miss you got this uh just mercy coming
up like there's a whole bunch going on
did you ever think that this was a
possibility because it's rare yeah you
know what I mean
yeah no definitely not I I wanted to be
a writer you know that was that was
really well
goal was I was all about creating the
world that these characters are in
they're not not playing one but when the
Straight Outta Compton happened it
wasn't about acting in a movie for me it
was about you know cementing my family's
legacy so something that I had to take
and from there was just making it work
so I wanted to make sure that I picked
roles that were night and day from you
know my first film just to show that I'm
serious about you know my acting and I'm
here to stay you know I'm here to make
some noise to other things I want to ask
you
number one is Dennehy's to happening I
don't know Christian go to gas it's
dinner think no I'm definitely down for
dinner at these two I feel like we left
it way too open we got to make sure we
close this Nick big Nick can't catch
Donnie Wilson I promise right because
also it did really well yeah yeah it was
one of those movies where you'd think
they want to do I think they've talked
about oh yes oh no we've definitely
talked you know we just got to get some
paperwork my last thing for you are you
gonna do are you even thinking about cuz
I asked your dad there's a you know
maybe you guys working together you know
like a father-son time yeah it's come
yeah are we gonna say when is that
coming I'm not quite sure I gotta get
done with this long shot and Godzilla
press but yeah we got something cooking
and this it's right around the corner I
promise and there we go thank you so
much man
you